deux femmes engagées auprès des enfants
pour deux espaces familiaux de
guyancourt d'un côté madeleine brès
premier docteur en médecine devenu
pédiatre de l'autre l'artiste joséphine
baker mère de douze enfants adoptés de
nom donné au nouveau lieu d'accueil
enfants parents et relais d'assistants
maternels des espaces inauguré samedi 6
avril avec la présence de trois enfants
de joséphine baker
moi je suis très fier ma famille est
aussi que l'on pense à célébrer ou
honorer le nom de ma mère dans des lieux
consacré à l'enfance et aussi à la
tolérance
ces deux espaces dédiés à la petite
enfance et à la parentalité viennent
compléter l'offre de services de la
commune dans ces domaines cela permet
aussi d'avoir des échanges entre parents
et parfois pour sa part ans c'est
l'occasion de sortir un petit peu
d'isolement parce qu'ils sont un peu
seuls chez eux notamment quand les
enfants sont pas encore nés et
scolarisés ou alors dans une structure
telle que la crèche pour l'europe c'est
elles savent et ils demandent des
escomptes maternelle puisque on a une
centaine d'assistantes maternelles sur
la ville aujourd'hui ce sont tes démunis
pour que leurs enfants puissent avoir un
lien un échange avec d'autres
assistantes maternelles la caisse
d'allocations familiales a contribué à
ce projet notamment avec un
investissement de 109 mille euros c'est
évident qu'on ne peut pas laisser les
parents seuls dans cette grande tâche
parce qu'on n'est pas bons on le devient
avant toute chose ces deux nouveaux
services vont fonctionner en alternance
sur le même site